foreign
Oklahoma great let's go to Oklahoma and
talk to Stacy what's up Stacy
hi Dr John what's up
oh not much so
that's the most Oklahoma answer not much
everyone in my family died that's right
exactly I know it
So speaking of boundaries if we are all
right let's do it so I have been in a
relationship with my fiance for about
three years
he has a 15 year old son he's had a
history of addiction
um he has
about eight months ago came and lived
with us but there was there there were
rules set in place like if it if you
bring it to my house if you use whatever
then you no longer live here
so can I just pause for a second yes
absolutely good for you
good for you do you have your own kids
yes so we also share
um an hour's child that is 14 months old
okay
[Laughter]
which so about eight months ago
he asked to come to our house and stay
there he wanted to come live with us so
this boundary was set in place
now that about three weeks ago he almost
died of a fentanyl overdose in my
bathtub
when nobody was home and the cops had to
come kick the door down I have said
you're not living here anymore
that was my boundary good for you what I
need to know is how do I stand in that
boundary when I feel like it's being
pushed back against me like now that
it's actually happened and I've set that
ultimatum in place to say no this is
where my daughter lives you were told
what the consequences would be now you
have done that you don't get just to
just say she just doesn't want me living
there because she's mean and she doesn't
like me the the 15 year old doesn't get
a vote
and that's
exactly whatever talking about what
about is it your fiancee yeah that's
right fiance is pushing back yeah first
of all he's he enables him you know he
purchases his nicotine
THC infused CBD because of his quote
anxiety well he's had way too much leash
to begin with as far as I'm concerned
but this was the boundary set in place
when you came to live with us
this has now happened you're out
Stacy that's the easy part that's the
easy part yeah your problem is not with
this 15 year old boy your problem the 15
year old boy is the proxy war
yeah your problems with this guy you're
dating
here's what I think I think he told you
things are going to be different and you
you get to have a lot of influence over
your little girl you all live together
we do okay so you you get to have a lot
of influence over this little girl's
life and your husband goes along with it
yeah and he doesn't like to say no to
anybody
whether it's you or his 15 year old
that's absolutely the truth and now you
are getting to see in real time holy
crap this is who this guy actually is
right and it's really gross
oh it's it's bad I mean it's physically
the
the physical anxiety that I get when
when this when he is around
is debilitating I mean it's the number
one problem in our relationship I mean
he has to disagree I disagree
prescriptions not he's not the biggest
problem the biggest problem in your
relationship is you and your fiance
right it's just a point of contention I
guess I should say it's true but the
bigger contention is your husband's
choosing his child which I'm gonna go
and say until y'all are married he
should be he should oh absolutely
absolutely and I agree with that and
but you have another child to protect as
well that's right and he's not and that
is my child and not I mean nothing will
happen to her yes I mean literally Over
My Dead Body it's not gonna happen I
mean he has stolen money prescription
drugs yeah he's my friend he's a 15 year
old with addiction
right and now that it's to the point
that it has reached like maximum level
like my my boundary is she and I will
not be around him but Stacy every six
years you're trying to convince me I'm
with you I know why are you trying to
convince me same team because for three
weeks this has been my life day and a
day out like just constantly I would
quit having the conversation because
you're making yourself insane
oh I know I am look the conversation's
over
yeah if now here's what this gets ugly
and messy and messy and ugly
you can look at your fiance and say if
you need to be with him I understand but
it won't be in this house
yes then that conversation needs that I
have not said those words it needs to
happen because you're both dancing
around it
yeah all of his excuses are you know he
needs us and it's a better place for him
to be here than his mom and he does he
needs to stand that but I don't want to
drug drug my infant or my toddler
through the trauma that I'm gonna have
to cancel out of her later if she finds
her brother dead there you go that is
exactly where we are I mean he almost
died in our bathtub luckily his
girlfriend was there to call an
ambulance but
other the alternative would have been
Stacy I find him I know it's just
exhausting Dr John it is but you are
exhausting yourself
I know I'm gonna tell you something
crazy but you gotta be my friend after I
tell it to you because yeah because I'm
gonna tell you straight
I will there's a great uh psychiatrist
is is uh he's probably in his 90s now
um his name is Irvin yalum
and he um it was is he's known for
existential psychology he's known for
all these great things but he is the
thing I think he's most known for in my
soul is he is a trainer of counselors
and he said
um something that stuck with me when I
was first training I was really young
into this mental health practitioner
thing and he said in a counseling
situation in an interaction with
somebody
everything is data
everything is data what here's what that
means
um we're not you and I are not in a
counseling relationship but we're
talking about what's the next right step
right right
he said if you're talking to somebody as
a therapist or as a coach and you find
yourself so unable to continue to pay
attention because the other person is so
boring probably
their wife experiences that and their
co-workers experience that and they
start to tune them out and shut him off
and that makes him nuts
and so call that out or if somebody is
smells really really top like it's
really rough and that means everyone
else in their life experiences that too
and so the idea was not only the things
that somebody's saying is everyone's
date is is data but how they how they
feel when you're interacting with them
okay so I tell you all that to say
I can feel how bottled up this stuff is
and how machine gun fire and exhausting
it all is
oh my gosh yes
because I'm going I really want to do is
just be her mama I don't want to there
you go this is just it's so much it
really is just so much but you keep
bringing gasoline back to the fire
stop just stop you have made your
decision you are right
and I'm gonna I'm gonna go one step
further I wouldn't
um if this was just about
a little boy who's struggling and I'm
gonna say a 15 year old this little boy
here a a child who is struggling with
addiction who is close to overdosing who
I that wouldn't be the reason
but I know and you know a kid struggling
with this type of opioid addiction who's
got a a mom whose home is not safe he's
got a dad with No Boundaries who's
stolen from family stolen from Friends
stolen from community members that's the
behavior I don't want my daughter around
correct I don't mind my children around
hurting people if there's adults to
regulate that interaction
you all don't have that because you have
an enabling adult
and it is it is beyond just a hurting
person it's a person who's now
inflicting harm in other people
that's what I'm going to separate my
daughter from I have no problem doing
that the problem y'all gonna run into is
y'all built a life together you created
a kid together you've been together for
three years and now there's a fracture
and you'll have to address the reality
of that fracture and blaming this 15
year old kid blaming I gotta protect my
baby all that's true but that's on the
outside what's on the inside is I don't
love a man who is so weak he won't help
his 15 year old son
um
I don't love a man who is so incapable
of helping his son
he's just gonna watch him die in our
bathtub for God's sake
I don't love a man who's so weak he's
just gonna put our four-year-old
daughter In Harm's Way like this
and like you mentioned even if the boy
is okay he's got girlfriends showing up
he's got a dealer showing up who knows
coming to your house
you are right
but that they aren't the problem the
problem is you have now had a
um a new pair of glasses with which to
view the man you're engaged to and you
don't like what you see
I know that's what you got to deal with
Fair yeah
fair I'm sorry that's okay I mean
I wouldn't have called if I didn't think
you were going to just tell me straight
so I hate that well I I well but I don't
want to pretend that I don't that this
isn't change everything
oh yeah
it does
if yeah the whole thing's a mess
I get that I'm so sorry I I mean I just
hate that for everybody
it is a mess for everybody I will say
this
I don't think that that your marriage is
is irredeemable I don't think this 15
year old boy is irredeemable
I don't think any healing happens until
somebody you've heard me say this but
somebody turns the lights on stops the
music and says this dance is over here's
reality from this point forward
yeah and then people get to make adult
decisions and opt in or out and that 15
year old may get the boundaries that he
needs desperately to survive
um or
he's going to die under somebody else's
roof because you are not going to sit
down and watch this happen no
absolutely right Fair
absolutely Fair
I hate this for you I'm sorry I know
that's okay I'd give you some
conversation cards that just feels like
I'm kicking you while you're down
oh geez all right well let me know how I
can help anyway as we as you move
forward through this and we'll be
thinking about you man
um
this is one of those calls that I you
can't button up with happily ever after
this is just a lot of really hard
boundaries and a really a lot I mean a
lot of hard conversations
and there's probably a lot of hurt and a
lot of tears and especially initially
as you say
as for me in my house me and my baby
girl we're gonna be safe and it doesn't
include this
thank you for the call Stacy call
anytime anytime anytime we'll have you
back